I'll be likely to see the mastermind
criminal threesome in a GTA 5 story DLC
well if we are no one's told Michael I'm
Dave and welcome to your game spot news
update Ned Luke to voice actor p on
grand theft auto 5 s michael de Santa
knows people want to see a single player
DLC but claims he knows nothing about
rock stars plans in that department
writing on facebook Luke said he doesn't
know when or even if Rockstar plans to
release single-player dlc for GTA 5
everybody one single player DLC but I
know nothing about that Luke told VG
24-7 don't know when it's going to
happen or even if it's going to happen
Luke went on to say that he will attend
a number of conventions this year
alongside Shawn fonteno and Steven OGG
the voice actors behind Franklin and
Trevor from GTA 5 lube didn't name any
specific conventions though there are
plenty to choose from around the world
this year it's interesting that the trio
would be embarking on a convention tour
this year when no new concept for GTA 5
outside the GTA online updates has been
announced the latest speculation around
GTA 5 single-player DLC cropped up last
week when a container posted a picture
of himself at Instagram in a motion
capture suit rockstar has said it's
exploring the idea of single-player
story content for GTA 5 but has made no
official announcements so would you buy
a DLC that reunited the thieving trio
let us know in the comments section
below or you can find me on Twitter at
irregular Dave and for all your GTA news
keep an eye on gamespot com